hey brian how are you balls are they
hairy uh not right now you know they're
not completely not completely hairless
they're just yeah tidy they're tidy
enough why is that monster yeah exactly
yeah do you know those guys are the
official sponsor i didn't even know this
of the ufc those guys are the guys that
help keep the balls of ufc fighters trim
that's the thing right you're getting in
the octagon you don't want hairy balls
if you want their package their product
package 4.0 4.0 4.0 we've been here
since 2.0 we did 3.0 now we're doing
four life has really we're helping you
guys upgrade as you go because there's
only going to be better ways to trim
your board so the hardware just keeps
getting better and better because the
slot they're on it i just want to let
people know out there right yeah if
you're a man trim your knows his i don't
feel right with a really hairy nose you
know i mean i need things to feel smooth
that right now
you could have your dinner off it yeah
exactly yeah and you would want your
dinner off it the point is they keep me
smooth with the weed but also they keep
me sharp they also keep you discounted
brian because i believe and i had to
look this up in my notes here just to
make sure it was true twenty percent off
and free shipping with code pain game on
manscape.com well i've been getting i've
been getting tattoos lately yeah and
i've been using mindscape the prep
really shave before i lie yeah yeah
because i mean it's it's it's the safest
way possible and so if you get manscaped
20 off and free shipping using the
copayne game on
manscape.com and you and your sparring
partner will be thanking us very soon
happy sparring oh you're going to be
sparring matt
i'll see you hitting the g spot after
all this
we have a good time we have a good time
thanks for coming see ya
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
fight this was designed for me to do
what makes us who we are
i'm so far ahead
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a map like that
to me i was born to do this
nobody can get close i'm
[Music]
welcome back to the pain game podcast
today's guest it's my old mate vidal
riley come on what's the realest it's
been a few years since our one last one
tour one yeah four
four years yeah it's flying [__] mad
it's flying well i don't look the same
though you know not aging yet yeah
we're like old mates now do you know
what i mean like it's been has been
inspired each other you've hit me i've
hit you you've done your things i i text
uh text you the other day i was getting
tattooed they were like that looks
painful i was like not as not as bad as
a punch in the face of you but it's
pretty bad like and and i replied with
their player that's true
no one must admit right when i was
watching your last fight obviously i've
never spoiled you properly like you know
people have seen how you spoiled eddie
yo you look after people in there you're
not trying to like
you know take the piss
but when i was watching the last guy you
fought i was saying to like people
around me i was like you know this guy
this guy's made of stone by the way
because like each of those punches
i have an idea of what they're going to
be like so fair [__] to the guy you
know what i mean i was surprised i was
surprised at how much he took but at the
same time i wasn't he's he's a veteran
yeah we knew he's an opponent that
if we hit do the right things we can get
rid of him but you know i mean the first
round he's trying to survive yeah he
knows how to survive he knows his way
around the ring yeah and i learned a lot
in that fire so i'm just ready to go
again now yeah i wondered how that would
be feeling because
uh the pressure must have been on you
you've been out the ring for so long on
the injuries that kept you out covered
had kept you out you've been
uh coming back from america you've been
through a lot actually for a young man
because people forget because you're a
big guy like you're still young as [__]
how old do you know 24. right 24 okay
so
you've already got like all of these
followers you've got a reputation
like people forget like mcgregor was
only 24 when he was just starting to
take off in the ufc so you're ahead of
the game in many regards but there was a
lot on your shoulders coming into that
fight and i think it showed a little bit
definitely yeah um i got over eager
enough i i felt that um but all the
factors that you named just there of
course they play a part and in hindsight
we can always say all right yeah it
really did play a part at the time
you're just trying to block it out and
get on with what you need to do
um but i was excited to fight i knew
people was wanting to see something
impressive it's my first fight under a
new promoter you want to show your
skills
you know what's all the hype about
and um i was boxing brilliantly in the
beginning let it knock down that knock
down by the way i'm glad that knocked
down
because you know it just shows the
skills that are there and i haven't even
showed all of them yet but the knockdown
came
to me when your mind was clear it was a
reactionary thing and you were a very
great reactionary fighter
and it was so natural but the minute
that happened i feel like you started
overthinking i was like right now i've
got to get him out of here from that
point
i got eager for the finish yeah i wanted
i wanted to finish i spoke about it i
trained for it
um
but yeah you can't force those things
we've seen eddie hall right the world's
strongest man yeah the bit the neck on
this guy and even he at one point goes
to you can you tone the [__] power
down yeah and i i watched that right i'm
one of the few people who could watch i
go i know what that feels like bro
i don't know what that feels why don't
you wear a head gun yeah
i guess he's trying to
get himself ready
we could definitely talk about the thor
in eddie fight i tell you eddie didn't
keep his power down on me
oh yeah he's swinging i noticed that
yeah and i feel like because in eddie's
head
he's
i know how that feels anyway i remember
thinking
i'm a baby
in skill compared to you yeah i might
have the power but in my head i was
always thinking ah he'll do the right
thing at the right time but sometimes
even pros don't and he did he did catch
you a little bit here and there no he
caught me with one big one yeah
he did catch me throughout the spa of
course there's boxing uh-huh but i mean
one of them was was a hefty swing i
thought i was at a range you know trying
to look pretty and big swing came out
he's fast for a big guy saw a couple
stars for a bit look leona's let's give
me some water
this please let's move now yeah next
round i'm gonna get you that should make
you feel something though because like
you know you've take like obviously he's
not a pro boxer but how many people are
going to be able to hit like he can
like you if you can take that you you
got an important what i'm learning
throughout my journey is it's important
to always reference what you've done you
know part of
me staying humble
is just moving doing what i do and move
yeah but it's important when you're
putting yourself in certain situations
go back reference what you've done
remember what you've done because when i
look at what i've done
in boxing
every bit of nerves leaves my body
that's interesting because when you're
stepping through those robes and we
could say on camera for example that you
know eddie is twice the size of you in
terms of like just sheer thickness and
density there
and yet you are you look loose you look
relaxed you don't look at someone who's
in fear by any means but like
even for you is there a shred of like
for me if this guy hits me i mean i mean
you know we've got to be honest when i
was squaring with eddie i didn't think
about it too much i just knew
you you got force you're gonna you're
gonna swing with force
um but i didn't think about it too much
once he hit me on the arm and just
little things where he wasn't landing
cleanly but my body's still shifting i
said okay
right now i'm dealing with it it's a
different a different animal right
because he could hit your shoulder and
you you move like he's hit in the face
yeah and i'm like okay cool this is what
i'm doing and then so in your in your
last fight was your big comeback fight
your highlight moment in that fight was
early on reactionary not thinking you
land the uppercut he goes down and in my
head i'm like right this is over you
know what i mean i'm assuming you're
feeling the same i was feeling
yeah i thought okay i was watching him i
knew he was gonna get up
and i thought one more shot
one more shot in our game instead of
let's continue having fun let's play the
game that's it i'll get him again yes it
was more like one more i'mma done your
dance yeah one more but then that boxing
is not our box so it's about staying
true to myself that's and it's
experience i'm learning i'm only going
to get better obviously i know that your
dad's been training you for a long time
now behind the scenes to gear you
towards making you the prize fighter
changing the style from amateur guy who
outpoints his opponents and makes them
look silly
um and because it's about a different
thing entirely prize fighting isn't it
and
um and you could say that that was
paying off in there it was just a case
of he was just shelling up and not
committing the essence of the amateur
game is point scoring
and the essence of the pro game is
damage
you scored on damage
whoever does the most damage normally
wins yeah so there's adjustments you
gotta make for that
he
felt damage early when he was being
positive if he stayed positive
i would have stopped him yeah maybe you
showed you showed him a little too much
too soon right and i feel like once i
knocked him down he thought well i'm not
playing this game i'm going to do my
absolutely yeah and i fell into his
hands by
letting him get away with doing his game
yeah his game was i'm going to spoil and
survive i let him swallow and survive
whereas in the beginning when he was
trying to fight me i'm thinking he's
this guy coming out starting for us
triple jabs who does he think he is he
got put down people will have heard your
dad actually in that fight it's not hard
to
miss his west you know he's very
prominent we we were howling when we
were watching it back because obviously
we know derek so well now from the
documentary
and you can hear him two three [__]
attack
and i was like oh listen i can hear it i
hear it when i'm walking on the road on
a normal day yeah it stays in my head it
has to now as well because
i know the advice is giving me is
correct absolutely i know the advice
he's given me i follow it i get to the
top yeah and i can't let emotions get in
the way of that i can't get over excited
and not listen because i know he when it
comes to boxing
you don't get give me anything wrong
yeah that's funny when i was watching
you right i was hearing your voice in my
head because so much of what i know
about boxing i learned from you
obviously
and one of the things that you taught me
that i've never really considered while
watching boxing and your dad says it as
well obviously it's like that tap bang
like
like the power variables in your punches
can
give the other guy the illusion of oh
i'm not i'm all right yeah i'm all right
yeah yeah and you weren't doing that at
the time because you were ferocious in
there you know i mean you were going for
the kill same intensity yeah but i i
kept thinking if you just give him that
illusion of safety
you'll be gone in about two seconds you
know and that's what again reminds you
is a game yeah it's a game boxing's a
painful game the playing game itself
but
it is a game yeah and when when playing
playing possum
lowering your opponent into doing what
you want them to do
is a major part of the game you can't
crash the front door down to get results
especially as the level goes up yeah and
i mean even like anthony joshua and then
like found that out the hardware really
like yusik joshua was a classic example
of that in my opinion it's this
technique yeah there's ways it's a game
yeah music plays the game
masterful brilliantly yeah beautiful
aspect i've watched that fight so many
times back because to me it's like in
order for you to come up away class and
navigate a bull in anthony joshua the
way he did and make him look silly took
his punches yeah and when he did connect
he took the punches but there were so
many times where aj was like where is it
like you can't land when you can't lock
your target yeah you can't land yeah and
using mastered that concept he
understands something has to be moving
at all times i mean they're they're
we'll get on to them actually because
they're rematching this year obviously
uh u6 has been fighting a war which [__]
knows what that's going to do it seems
like some sort of thing out of a movie i
feel like aj has a lot to change
um i don't think he should get too
invested in the whole if i was more
aggressive i would have won thing
because as we spoke about in my
situation certain factors you're more
aggressive you're going to get hit more
yeah
you can't discredit that
so and music knows what everyone's
saying
yeah he's he switched on and he switched
on so he knows what you're going to come
hard at his time obviously you want your
belts back naturally you gotta take
something that's yours you're gonna try
harder to get back so i think he knows
what to expect yeah the the one hope for
aj that i i when i rewatched the yusik
fight was um i think was around the
middle of the fight
there's a shot that lands on music
music backs the [__] off is it a red
hook i think it might have been like or
straight right and but i remember
thinking that's the moment that's where
you've got to go
and
in my opinion the the strategy for aj
could be
look you're going to lose rounds that's
just going to happen yeah but you have
to when that that single moment happens
where you do hit him
or you got to unload the clip at that
point and go [__] hell for leather
that's the thing
it's a difficult one because we don't
really see using her
he stumbled back but how hurt is he
that's a uh element you have to remember
because again you can stumble back is it
goes i look at him he's about to run in
and who knows what happens then and and
we've seen ruiz
when we believed ruiz was vulnerable in
the first fight against aj and that's
when the count has come in so it's it's
a difficult fight for aj to win a back
music to win it
just because i feel like what he knows
is ingrained into him it's not new
lessons these things that he's been
doing so it's going to be hard to beat
someone who knows more than you
and has been doing it for longer well
it's kind of like what we were saying
about your fight and that the the
difficulty you had was when you started
thinking and and for aj you can see
second guesses himself quite a lot
whereas zusik is just playing the game
playing the game that's it and and the
fight can be won by any any man aj
proved in the first fight he's got
skills to beat you he's capable of being
music but how much of those moments can
he get in the next set of 12 rounds that
they have yeah we've got the the big
fight coming up on the weekend yeah fury
versus white
you spawned dillian white yes what was
it like being in the ring with him oh so
i spotted him i think we've done like
four rounds
i think
when heavyweights spar with lighter
people
the speed puts them off
that's what i think i'm nothing
especially at that time where i was
still definitely more in amateur mode
than i am now
the first four rounds i was always going
to do what i'm doing move around yeah
like he's looking for me looking for me
and he's not the fastest on his feet
either no
you're graceful
right yeah so it's like when i i used to
get i used to get happy about things
like that but then you realize
they're pros they played a game
completely different he's not thinking
about punching you until around six
really if you're you know what i mean oh
by around six seven we would really see
what's happening his fault four rounds
he's got another sparring partner
waiting on the outside he's probably
trying to chill because he knows the guy
that's coming in for the next fours you
know i'm gonna be more tired he's
fresher let me reserve myself i ain't
gonna go all out on vidal but
definitely for the four rounds it was
thinking i don't want to get hit by you
i know you swing some overhand right
it's wild signature overhand right yeah
his left hook is short on point
so those are the two things i thought
about and i kind of just kept a look
kept in long range moved around pick my
punches so the last two fights he had
against povetkin i think we've seen
the best and the worst of them uh in
those two fights i think uh he
just demolitioned him in the rematch but
then we've seen with that uppercut we've
seen aj knock him out with the uppercut
that can knock him out with the uppercut
and it's it's this spot on him and i
just believe that it's this one thing
about him if he hit that spot
boom he's he goes and he seems flatlines
as well when it happens it seems that
way i don't know i'm not saying he's got
a glass jar because no no i've seen the
guy he's been in wars and he's taking
like some of the aj shots were
unbelievable
what i mean is it's just that one i feel
like it's that one punch that just for
whatever reason it can be his undoing
because he didn't take much damage at
all against povetkin in that first fight
he was on top he was cruising and then
boom
lights out and povetkin you know he's
he's built to hook like he's built for
short punches when it comes to hooks and
uppercuts his body shape even you can
see he's designed for
short demolition and then by slipping on
the outside from that shot yeah
brilliant i think white and fury is a
close fight up until
round six i think fury's pace
that lean and grabbing and picking and
dancing and switching and it's too much
but
i see fury getting dropped down oh a gun
yeah i put that i i predict that early
really because i think there's they're
gonna they might scrap for a bit see i i
i look at that fight and i feel like if
fury wants to he can make it very easy
for himself but knowing the ego of the
man that's why and what the show he
wants to put on i don't know if he'll do
that's the angle yeah if he if he if he
wanted to click score him and just leave
without a mark on him he could do that
he's in he's a showman again he's got 94
000 people there
after that ring walk and white's looking
at him he's gonna go for it he's gonna
go for a little a [__] you know let's
let's see what you got and then he might
get dropped what not something happened
then he gets up and he says you know
what i know i'm a better boxer than you
i'm just gonna outmuscle you out box you
frustrating for aj watching
the the road that theory is taking
because when i watched aj's fight back
at the start of uh the ruiz defeat and
the easy game sorry
he at the start of the fight you hear
the commentators go and if he can get
past this one that sets up the mega
fight yeah and aj's legacy is missing
the mega fights
the deontay wilder the the tyson fury he
doesn't have that on and although his
actual record is there's a great you get
two different types of reputations you
can fight the best fighters which aj has
done
no one can ever say otherwise don't want
to hear it he's definitely thought the
best fighters but he hasn't fought the
fight as people want to see him that's
the problem yeah that and at the end of
the day we're here to entertain the
people
aj needs that fight
more than fury in terms of the people
not his credentials of course he's
already two-time hearing in the world
but i mean the people have jumped that i
feel like the people have jumped ship a
bit now yeah like the fact that fury's
now holds the record for wembley
is c and and aj's been in wembley yep
and in fury now holds the record these
things are going to irritate you these
things are going to irritate you and
it's going to make you want to fight
that guy and i hope
that fight
happens regardless of
aj
being music or not because no one's
going to remember the belts that were on
the line i promise you we walked down
the street 15 years ago you remember the
wba wbc was on the line you know no
one's going to say that they're going to
say do you remember the fight so
hopefully that fight happens for that
reason have you seen david haye again
has picked against tyson fury he always
does i know it's so funny though because
it whines old man furious so much he's
got a little gradually yeah he does it
was supposed to fight twice yeah i think
and uh
that would have been i would have david
here pulled out both times yeah and see
that
you don't probably don't want to hear
about fury you know it must wind them up
yeah i feel like he's saying it and he
means it i don't know i don't think he's
coming from a spiteful place but i feel
like it's easier for him to go against i
think there's a hint of just because of
that
that little history i think he's
trolling a little bit because um john
look you weren't you in the i was in you
did something with john
woodley and jake you've done the thing
we're standing around yeah so you've met
john so you you understand the man he
was cool i was expecting more i was
expecting him to be
more on me because i wasn't like backing
tommy like that for the for the j fight
but i think i know how to talk well so
i also think that um you know you're
seeing how uh big john spoke to uh um
cole frampton sorry and carl frampton's
like looking at the big john and he's
like i used to respect you
and
i'm like man you [__] stood your
ground there fair play to call from then
like but you know what john john
you don't need to go around doing that i
mean yeah he's entitled to his opinion
do you think he'd ever do that to you
just i probably would he probably would
but i'm not going nowhere if that
happens yeah i mean i'm just calling
that he's been saying yeah i don't even
need to do that i don't even need to do
that he'll be there anyway i don't even
have to call my dad
he's right there anyway but i mean he's
built how he's built i'm built
you're not gonna just talk to me like
that no you know and frampton obviously
felt that way because he was there yeah
and uh i just feel like it's unnecessary
though you don't need to
to to put light on yourself
for things like that because
no one rates it you know i mean we're
going to talk about it for a couple of
tweets and then it's dead uh tommy's
actually on the undercard the other yeah
it's not a great undercard but they put
tommy on he's against a ten and one
fighter
uh him and jake paul were gonna fight
tommy pulls out
now i think tommy has to earn
that back again
it's just mad in it he's trying to earn
a fight
with the guy that's you keep saying
he's not a boxer you're trying to earn a
fight with him
exactly exactly not making sense but
yeah um i don't know much about his
opponent the la so the last fight that
the two of them had uh tommy for that
little wrestler yeah uh what's his name
anthony yeah that's it pretty bad taylor
i mean he fought on the the youtube the
show's starting yeah and he didn't look
good on that and and you're thinking
like because logan told me that he
spotted anthony and that he got him out
there in a round right after being on
the piss for like i believe him and i do
as well but because of the way he just
spoke so like confidently about it
wasn't like bragging he was like mate i
got this guy out there in one round
after being on the piss for three months
or whatever and after watching this
anthony taylor fellow in his in his
youtuber boxing thing i thought yeah
he's bad
he's not good mma fighter predominantly
a short little one as well he ain't like
he's even comparable in size short
little one you know what i mean he's not
even on tommy fury's leveling
he should have got rid of him and the
fight he won it but it was like it was
it was all right you won but like you
were supposed to get him out of there
but but
you didn't even like it you didn't even
look good against him you know what i
mean
and jake spars with taylor yeah and i'm
sure when jake is sparring with him he's
probably practicing a few bits and
pieces and i don't think he's trying to
take his head off so this is the thing
when big john gets offended by people
not picking his son against jake it's
like did you watch your son's last fight
we don't
yeah he's supposed to do that yeah but
just allow us man if we don't think that
we don't think that yeah but this to be
honest with you the one thing i will say
is tommy did show
more variety of boxing skills against
anthony than jake did against tyron
woodley true i felt like tyron woodley
the last fight although the knockout was
spectacular it was a [__] bang and
knockout do you think the fight wasn't
great
great knockout
do you think tyrone was winning that
fight i had to have two quick questions
do you think do you think taran was
winning i
thought it was one of those fights where
it was so bad you kind of what you think
like it's like i don't really want to
score this for anyone it's just so bad
like i was watching jake and i was
thinking where are your fundamentals
where is the job what would you have
done
if you was a judge ringside what would
you have been doing who would you where
would you have been edging the fire i
can't to be honest with you i can't
remember because i remember watching we
watched it live and i remember saying
that lauren's like they're saying good
bro like i i got to a point where
because i want jake to do well because
it's better for me it's better for our
industry the more noise he makes the
easier my life is right so i've got
content you know how it is and i was
just like thinking like
the last fight you guys had wasn't good
this is probably worse
and
like i just remember thinking i'm not
seeing the development in jake's game
right now that i expect it to be seeing
so i kind of just shut down from scoring
it was not bad i think i think tyrone
was was winning the fight not by not by
much at all and if it weren't jake's
where you get ain't no one's saying
anything but no one looked good no and
then that knockout came saved there do
you
you mentioned uh
tommy
showing more technical ability against
anthony taylor do you think he would
have showed more technical ability
against tyron woodley because i don't
think so i think it would have i think
when there's someone on the on the
opposite side of the ring who can hurt
you which tyron woodley can
i don't think he would have been as
confident and he's putting his punches
together
um in the way he was i think he i don't
think he would have been to be honest so
that's where the interesting thing
between him and jake comes and that's
why there's a debate here and that's
what i think
john doesn't understand
is that when we don't automatically go
bucks are not a box that's like
we're looking at it for what it is you
know it's not really close mate yeah not
for the title given you can't judge
people in their title yeah you have to
judge them who made them a box office
because you had boxing fights
and fights you think uh tommy beats
tyron
yeah yeah by a decision though i don't
think i don't think he knocks tyron out
the way jake did i think that's one
thing jake commits to his punches in a
way i don't think tommy does but tommy
has a nice
you know he's been around boxing so long
he's amazing he's a nice toolbox
some of his shots and some of his little
moves i'm like oh that was all right you
know i do see little things here and
there
but
i don't know if it's up there with him
you know whereas jake i think it's got
the mentality of a fighter i've been
impressed with um his coach in his
interviews um
cj flores i've always been impressed
with everything he had to say but i know
it's his first time coaching a fighter
and i know it's different when you've
got you know gabe coming towards you as
opposed to tyron woodley but some of his
backwards fighting and his basic jobs
and stuff against gabe i felt like were
more like cleveland right right then
against tyrone woodley and i'm like well
that was two years ago why
what was true what happened
when you when i reflect on it yeah like
when gabe was right on him i thought wow
he's really dealing with this pressure
quite well here whereas against woodley
i don't know what happened and he did
say afterwards to be fair to jake and
this is me being a hater because i like
the kid but it was like he's like i
don't know my legs just felt like jelly
again and
i was like i don't know what's going on
there it's weird yeah maybe
what like what he's done he needed a
rest
it's intense he trains hard he's
fighting very often i wonder who's gonna
be next could be uh apparently nate diaz
wants to do it nate diaz i feel like
he's been wanting that fight for for a
while yeah it's a good fight we know
that
nate is known even in the mma room for
his boxing yeah so it's a nice you know
okay you got good hands no one can tell
me you're a wrestler let me fight you it
makes sense and he's and he's taller
it's gonna look much more comparable in
like height and all of that and the the
the pre-fight hype would be great the
only thing is i think the ufc have known
what the plan is so they've held on
tonight's contract
and and with conor mcgregor coming back
they've locked nate in and gone
do the trilogy with mcgregor and then
we'll let you go
so i think that's going to be mcgregor
this is not next fight i guess that's
good for nate as well
that's not bad i know maybe if it's not
what he wanted to do he's going to be a
bit pissed about it but
you're going to cash out
you know you people always care about
you two fighting because there's history
there and then back to back another
another payday against and he's got a
better chance against mcgregor after
coming off of a broken leg than ever in
my opinion like this is not going to be
mc vintage mcgregor it can't be after
that like i'll be shocked if it if he
would be at 170.
it'll probably be 170 mcgregor coming
off the injury if you beat mcgregor and
then bounce and then go straight into
jake paul
that's what i mean that's a good look so
the ufc they sound like pagans
but they might actually be setting them
up because they don't think yes yeah you
know it sounds like if you look at it on
the reverse side well they're trying to
find anyone who mcgregor could fight on
a comeback fight really and like nate's
one of the few who he'd probably have a
chance against at the top level i don't
want to see mcgregor again i don't want
to see him again if he is i will watch
it because i like fighting of course but
i mean i don't want to just you you're
good you're good yeah what you do you're
good yeah it's really that's me he's
calling out kamaru uzman why
yeah you've just lost back the back
fights with dustin poirier it doesn't
make sense oozeman everything dustin
pourier brings to the table his man does
better times it by ten yeah like he's a
dominant champion like extremely dumb
as well like and versatile when he
knocked out mas vidal that was like a
shot heard around the world he hasn't
even been using his wrestling recently
he's been using his boxing
he's been practicing his stand-up going
into fights and saying you know i'm
gonna practice stand up today
and then he's so he's got that covered
and then he's going to take mcgregor
down and just stand in it yeah you could
do it any way he wanted to and that
another thing is like i don't think
mcgregor understands the power
difference between a him and an uzman
yes i know guzman walks around
cruiserweight hmm like 200 pounds
210 yeah something like that that's
crazy beast and then he diets down to
170. he's a street big guy the thing
that made me i think the colby fights
made me realize how great it was money
is but burns chimaya did you watch this
fight recently no right i didn't
have the this
this sensation from yeah i've seen a lot
about him
you have to watch this fight right one
of the best fights this year boxing mma
doesn't matter right unbelievable right
now now burns burns uh rocked oozeman in
their first fight and then usman went on
the job and not and just finished him
after a few rounds just destroyed him
burns gave cosmic chimaya of kittens
like he really had him in a war where he
had to dig dig dig deep and even at the
end burns is hooking him in the head
like it was so competitive and that's
when you realized that
this is someone who been dealt with
quite comfortably really after that one
shot that he took early on
if i'm mcgregor i'm thinking
you can appreciate his skills
differently yeah with having that
comparison yeah and then and then conor
mcgregor was talking about in a comeback
fight he's going to take on oozman are
you mental listen proper 12 is banging
it's everywhere he's drinking too much
of it
you're good that's what i mean you're
good you've got he's got his suits
he's he's
always
what do you want to do
what's your plan it's equal to me and
this is the thing is like i feel like
he's going to come back and someone's
going to destroy him who he thinks again
like like dustin not on my level in
reality he's going to be like knocking
at the door isn't it like which is sad
you don't want the fight i'd have to get
out of that i've seen it a lot though in
in the fight game i mean the card's just
gone from legends that go outside hmm
it's not a good look
you know they're still legends and we
still go with holyfield at any time when
we're still like wow but it's like oh
don't worry don't watch the end of it
watch him watch him until 2000 and did
it after that i don't watch it because
you're not going to really see what he's
like you know just give the people what
you you're your best
and leave it that's how i look at that's
how i view the game absolutely and like
i i i just interviewed muhammad ali's
grandson not long ago
and nico yeah and um
and when i was doing my research on ali
it really hit me like how sad it was at
the end for him and that's
like the ultimate boxing story you know
and like you think [__] me just quit
while you're ahead it's true but no one
but he's achieved when your achievements
are so great people don't even talk
about it yeah i'm sure there's a small
percentage of people that realize how
muhammad ali's career actually ended
yeah but it's not about it's not even
just about the people it's about the
damage
that you could have saved yourself
you know fighters when we're fighting we
don't think about that because of course
we're thinking about fighting but you
gotta know when it's time
these things are gonna stay with me now
that fight is going to stay with me yeah
you gotta let go
one of the one of the other big
youtubers uh logan paul has called out
paddy the baddies i see this how mad is
that right you you've met paddy on the
show yeah
he's
and we were hanging out with him before
the whole blow up of the ufc yeah yeah
and like i get why logan would want to
pick him it's
logan loves the publicity the magic and
paddy brings that
but like michael bisping's done a video
very recently calling logan a coward
for
picking on someone who's a lot smaller
than him in terms of actual fight in
weight obviously paddy fights 155
i think logan something like 195.
big big difference big difference uh
what logan said was look i can make 185
paddy balloons up we'll meet somewhere
in the middle
and what bisping's saying is like why
don't you fight someone your own [__]
size sort of thing that's what he's
or someone like that you know um what's
your take on that because it would be in
the ufc it wouldn't be a boxing match
so paddy has
logan is is smart man he knows exactly
who to pick and with with um paddy he's
thinking i'm a big guy i wrestled
he's better than me but maybe the size
again with a bit of wrestling experience
i can do a little something and make it
seem like wow yeah logan could have done
it with me that's it the weird thing is
that for me would be a fantastic
entertainment it would and there's a lot
of money in it yeah so when i see him
say these things i'm like people just
straight away take out your head the
weight difference there's no belt on the
line here this is not no one's trying to
climb the ranks this is i'm getting paid
and the promo is going to be great and
you're all going to watch it and he
ticks those
and if i broke the fight down in my head
i'm like you know paddy can bang and he
probably hits a lot harder than any
harder than most lightweights do
he's got great submissions so if logan
takes him down he's logan in safe
protect his legs
and then you've got logan with a great
wrestling background we've seen logan
wrestle um paulo costa he [__] went
with paolo costa and rolled with him and
looked fantastic in wrestling and then
obviously logan's boxed so there's a
part of me that's like i [__] watch
the [__] out with that like i pay a
hundred quid you have to watch it i'm
watching it i'm watching it yeah i don't
think it's a ridiculous call out like i
understand why
and you i understand why you wouldn't
fight business either dana went on his
logan's podcast and he was like uh
you know let me fight the ufc and then
went i'm not saying no see and that was
the thing
that's it that's all he needed to do
so now he knows that that door is open
too yeah so this guy are coming we've
got to give him his flowers he's doing
wrestlemania on one minute how are you
doing wrestlemania that's a big
wrestlemania look god as well and he's
looking at doing suplexes three in a row
i was like yo i used to do this one on
my cousin
[Laughter]
on him
no he's he's a no he's good man he's i
rate what he's doing he knows how to
keep her business flowing oh yeah and
branch off also so i got nothing but
respect for logan obviously uh in the
world of youtube boxing as well jj is
coming in
he's coming back uh a lot of people are
leaking that it's gonna be like august
he's gonna put on a big boxing fight
talks of his opponent
he there he was chatting about thor on
the sidemen podcast but has since sort
of been like all right that was a yeah
it was a bit of a joke tonight sort of
thing or maybe someone's had a word with
him have you maybe have you talked i
haven't spoken to him
you know what jj is like man he goes off
saying
no one's going to stop him from saying
those things yeah that's who he that's
what he does but he could change his
mind again though my favorite thing was
he was like when he's recharging i'll
just hit him i was like mate this isn't
a boss on crash barbie
you know i mean he'll keep coming um but
uh it looks like alex wasabi yeah after
alex won against deji
um
first off like what do you make of that
as a match up uh i think it's a good
matchup for jj to take as his first
fight back after how many years three i
think three years three it's gonna be
almost three years yeah good opponent
you know get quick redemption for your
brother
and
i think he just hits too hard
people don't realize
how jj hits and alex is a smaller guy
he's a smaller anyway
once jj whacks in a couple of those
hooks
i think he gets wasabi out there three
rounds really yeah i think it's a good
opponent i honestly think it's good
to make him look like alex yeah yeah
alex he's got good shape he's fit you
can see he takes the the game serious
when he's he's been practicing it
he's
gonna dig deeper than he's ever
looked to dig before because he
understands what that does for him jj
realizes that he can't lose hence the
doc name
and they realize if i can win this
changes my life
alex wassabi is already big amongst the
community and his fans but now you
transcend over into a different sort of
theme if you the ksi shows that
yeah it becomes a big thing so he's
going to train in a mad way i should
anyway i think technically in that fight
he fought more technically as a boxer
yeah than jj has in his fight so far and
he probably if they fight
would that will probably be the same
more like the the boss yeah he might
look more like a boxer but jj is going
to whack him yeah it's like it's one of
them ones i agree it's not it's not
going to be the pretty who's prettier
it's going to be oh alex holding good
shape bang right hand ooh and
alex wants to make it competitive and
obviously we'll all be rooting for jj
but but i also want to see a good fight
and i want i don't want to squash much
in one round yeah no neither do it and i
think what alex would have to do is um
he'd have to play that you know hit and
not get a hit and run for the [__]
hills like you know
tag him move like usic type stuff
obviously it's not a trading battle yeah
you're definitely you know a trading
game plan you'd have to come in super
perfect so fast yeah keep running it's
not a trading video yeah he's gonna have
to really box around him and
have his strategy down pat jj as well
can't take alex wassabi for granted
that's the one worry i would have that's
the only worry as i kind of been a good
few years you forget about the grind
like obviously jj's kind of been
training in the background but not as
seriously as he once was uh that was a
difference yeah and
he just has to be like because when he
speaks so confidently there was a little
bit of as a friend you
all right just make sure you [__] put
the work in though yeah yeah of course
you want to know he's ticking the boxes
yeah you know um i hope so
you know this will be the first time he
fights and you guys don't see me exactly
in the corner that'd be weird it's gonna
be yeah it's gonna be a bit weird but
i've kind of i've
accepted that so when i see it i guess
it will come over me like hello i'm not
the one giving him advice but at the
same time i know it's that time in life
now um i i can't be that guy mm-hmm i've
got to give myself advice hey man you
you uh
you and him are undefeated together as
well so that's a nice way it's a good
way to leave it um i want to see wasabi
i want to see someone else that someone
i don't know
and then jake
yeah the jake fight that's always going
to be something people pay a [__] ton of
money to watch how much would you pay
i think that i think people
would pay like
anthony joshua money for that fight
a certain crowd i'm not talking about
boxing he's saying ticket sales not
people our crowd would pay anthony
joshua
especially if you went like
let's throw
the eddie thor rematch on the undercard
yeah
big mega show then yeah i'd say what so
no nobody was even there for everybody
ringside ticket i think it would be
massive yeah yeah i think it'll be huge
because jj is stopped now as the pop
star [__] rap
is so high jake now is basically the
biggest talked about guy in boxing other
than canelo
so
what it would have been ironically if
they'd fought originally is nowhere near
what it will be now
so if if if they accidentally have
stumbled onto making way more money than
fair fox
where
could hold that right it's gonna be
england people in america i don't think
are as
uh in tune
with uh this whole thing and this is
where it started so this is where it
should finish in a way like that is the
fight to finish it all in my opinion
because emirates uh i do you know what
it is they could probably [__] do
tottenham or something like that no no
we don't we don't want jj and something
because he's an arsenal fan yeah that's
true that's why i said emirates
yes
something like that like yeah yeah o2
yeah or two there's a capacity
difference
between o2 and the football stadium they
could do with stadiums i think they
could do a 60 000. because people will
travel
people from europe get quick flight yeah
for it i know because it's been like
years yeah it's been building for too
long and we've got some there's so many
communities
with large
followings that will come to that right
yeah the traditional boxing world will
be there
i just hope jj puts the work in because
we know jake has been putting the work
in and watching jake lately hit pads
just being brutally honest i've never
seen jj ever hit pads the way jake does
at the moment there is a gap there that
he has to catch i notice i'm a leap head
man i can't lie i know what you're
saying no
yeah like and just because you hit the
pads with better technique don't mean
you hit the person i'm talking about
obviously like the knockout of tyron
woodley yeah the the level jesus look
he's looking he's looked better yeah you
can't you can even jj acknowledges like
yeah even though he believes he'll win
he accepts like i have to make the
ground up yeah anyone that tries to say
that jj
looked better than jake has looked
would be guessing yeah yeah he's put the
time in jake jj has been doing the music
thing yes it's different even when he
was boxing is different they just but
that's what makes it
so intriguing
because if jj was looking so bad and
jake was looking so good why you've why
is the fight why do you think the fight
is even then well so eddie versus
thought obviously that went down
uh one of my favorite of this whole
celebrity fighting thing it was
possibly the best match in terms of
entertainment for me kind of felt
looking back at it when i was live
watching it i was doing my little
reaction i didn't really fully notice at
the time i thought it was like a ploy
from eddie that he'd been hiding the
whole time about how he was going to
fight i didn't really realize that
clearly one arm wasn't working
and then i felt sorry for eddie because
in my head i'm like i don't know why
you've had to take this fight in this
time i feel like there's another maybe a
contractual thing because
nobody in their right mind would go in
there with one arm against four
and yet he still dropped them
like credit daddy like the heart he
showed in just going for it um
but i i still believe that he can win
that fight if he has the right coaching
and um and both options
yeah this stuff with both arms first
yeah sort of give the coaches something
to work with yeah i mean but um i think
eddie done well man he done well as you
said putting it into perspective having
one army done well i felt like watching
the build up fight week
i thought
he's not entirely confident he's
overreact again angry a bit too much you
know when someone's getting angry a bit
too much is that where you saw it
that was so epic it was entertaining it
was press conferences
covering something you know when you
clearly was you know and that's what
he's exactly and you know he done his
thing
thought
he boxes well
he's you can tell whoever coaches him
understands the game and they're passing
it on to him
eddie
with two arms completely different fight
because like even as the fight going on
and he started to look in the legs but
it's easy to avoid that one weapon like
right and he's software anyway so he's
already moving to his natural
right
and you're swinging with your right i'm
just moving away from you at this point
i kind of i kind of wished i mean it's
easy to say this but i don't know how
bad the the bicep is obviously but i
kind of wish he'd even
fainted more with the with the injed arm
and just just put it out there and make
them believe of it yeah i mean it's like
that takes a lot of it takes more mental
capacity
than you think when you're so new to the
game yeah we're talking about me and how
i
can my brain can lead to me not boxing
how i should work so exactly and then
eddie who's just started
you're just thinking this um i can't use
it
but i'm still fighting i'm gonna hit you
with this one yeah to start thinking you
know i'm gonna faint even though this
one don't work like it takes it takes
some thinking you know i mean when
you're when you're in that position so
that's why i gave him his credit i
didn't like everyone they piled in on
him yeah
i didn't like that i felt bad for that
because in my head i thought i was like
okay i get his boxing technique they sat
in the other but like this is his first
ever fight and he's fighting a guy who's
six foot nine
i didn't respect it like
what did what does he have to do gain
your respect guys like yeah of course
he's not perfect at boxing he ain't a
boxer he's the world's strongest man did
you not read the title
like titan
i i tried it in my preview explaining
that people like these guys aren't like
they'll bear hug the life out of you if
they want you know what i mean like
they're [__] animals you i just want
them to hold out by i said
i don't know if sometimes you know when
an injury can put you out of it you just
go you know i don't even need to go back
now i'm gonna do movies or something
instead you know
he says he wants the real match that's
good i would like to see it but just go
in
a hundred percent i would change his
trainer putting that out there i know he
he spoke very highly of his trainer said
a lot of nice things but like i think
some minor adjustments in there would
have made him so much more effective and
he
i don't mean just the fight i mean all
of the training footage when i did my
prediction yeah everything i looked that
thor was doing technically was better
than eddie right everything but i looked
at eddie's power and i thought and speed
so in my head i was like okay
i get those the better boxer and i
always pick the better box out this is
the one time i didn't but i thought it
ain't going to matter at this age
because they're so young in their boxing
years eddie will just blitz him and he
nearly he nearly [__] did it was very
close it was very close the knockdown
was i was guessed when i see him fall
down halfway yeah good and he was
landing over and all that he's landing
and then when fatigue sets in
we all know how it is thinking about
boxing when you're tired and not injured
thought it thought in my respect i'm not
like i haven't been a fan of what he the
way tre eddie back in the day but like i
had to say like he
humbled himself and probably took a lot
of beatings in the gym in order to get
like to understand what he did you know
his management of the ring and all of
that was pretty clean like it was good
it was a good
spectacle and i think better than most
would have it would have fought like
fitness-wise
you done was it six rounds six threes as
well six freeze bring the rematch
with eddie having two arms
so sounds metal that's it it's that
simple
just just give them let him have two
arms and see how it goes yeah i do think
that a lot of people haven't [__] up
that in like because eddie didn't want
to be like the guy to make the excuses
on your future you got one soon because
i'm i'm sure you're trying to nothing i
can talk about even though you're my guy
you know i mean i can't say nothing
right now yeah uh on camera time frame
we're gonna be out before
my birthday's in july for those that
don't know i will be out before my
birthday yeah and then i wanna
make sure i fight a few more times this
year as well i know it's essential for
me to be in the ring so like four times
a year or something like that yeah well
it's just i know and i'm starting to
realize everyone's path is different
um so i'm just living mine um before we
go
i'm sure all the fans would want to know
how's direct doing he's all right you
know you're not talking about you
last fight week
but
but it was an accident something it was
an accident tonight he's showing me a
move i should have used all right yes
when i watched the clip back i've
already done that i probably would have
knocked him before this is too far too
my cousin over here ninj
he's a
a gas lighter all right yeah
he's a gas ladder so when him and my dad
together they bounce off each other
good energy all right yeah he got your
dad excited he he he got him in the mood
that's not a good thing no and i should
have moved my head because this fire
week anyway anything that comes at me i
should be slipping whether it's cheering
on punching whatever i should be on
point and um yeah he just showed me a
move bam bang and the two that that is
yeah man it's just it needed to come out
anyway right yeah it's it's listening
it's
it's fighting in it this is called
direct the democrats that's no no
that's
this is what we're talking about this is
this is what it's about
experiences things that people don't
know that's going on and they're not
judging you and then i sit down with
brand two months later and i'm like did
you know that same week
yeah i've got my tooth for done
you know about that that you know what
i'm saying so
it's good
and there's no you know it's me and my
dad anything of course what was it
we i've seen a little bit of footage
which i loved saying because it was like
the good old days of hearing derek's
words of wisdom on ifl when they had you
in the locker room yeah yeah what was it
like when you got home and you both just
sort of
right well we won what was that it was
that it was a good feeling because it
was building for so long you know my dad
we know he's my lifelong coach but it's
the first time he's been in my corner
yeah which is interesting it was nice to
see them interview him after so it was
like yeah we he's like yeah we've done
it and we didn't do it on a small show
yeah we didn't do it with an easy
opponent
and we have extremely high standards but
the win was still good fashion
so you know we had to look at it level
headed
and say
we know my potential
stretch is way higher than that
performance the next ones will keep
growing and improving but we've done it
now
that box is ticked now we're looking
forward to it mate we'll definitely get
you back on as you climb the rung so no
doubt have a belt around your waist
thank you hopefully if you do and just
pinned in yeah got to be done got to be
done that was without riley on the pain
game podcast don't forget to check out
his youtube channel doing the great
boxing content all of that good stuff
and roll and check you with your mates
all right and we will see you on the
next one
cheers you